- [Narrator] Russia has
been amassing troops
near its border with Ukraine for weeks.
(blades whirring)
The prospect of a possible attack
has triggered tense negotiations
and diplomatic efforts
as the US and NATO has been trying
to discourage Russia from
taking military action.
- Economics are very
difficult for Ukraine as well
being almost surrounded.
(Sergei speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] The stakes are high.
The West has threatened sanctions
and military deployment by NATO.
While Moscow says it doesn't
plan to invade the country,
it wants to have a say
in Ukraine's future.
Since Ukraine was invaded
by Russian troops in 2014,
it has strengthened its own military
and many Ukrainians say
they're ready to fight.
But what happens now also depends
on whether tensions between the US
and Russia keep escalating.
Moscow began stationing troops
and military equipment near
Ukraine in December of last year
as was documented by satellite images.
By early January, 100,000
troops were amassed not far
from Ukraine's border.
President Putin has long
claimed ties to Ukraine,
a former Soviet Republic,
and has repeatedly indicated
that he wants it back
under Russia's influence.
- In recent years, Ukraine
has sought to join NATO
and the EU.
These blocs are not offering membership
but Putin has accused
them of turning Ukraine
into an anti-Russia on
his country's borders.
(Vladimir speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Ukraine's
president, Volodymyr Zelensky,
said NATO has an interest
in supporting Kiev
to contain any fallout of a Russian attack
that could affect its member states,
especially in Eastern Europe.
- In the past, Russia has resorted
to military action to keep Ukraine close.
When the country ousted
its pro-Russian president
in a revolution in early 2014,
Moscow responded by seizing
Crimea in southern Ukraine.
That war and other conflicts
involving pro-Russian
separatists in recent years
have fueled a wave of
Ukrainian nationalism,
according to some socialists.
- Before 2014, a lot of people felt
quite positive about Russia.
Now a lot of people in
Ukraine see it as an invader.
- [Narrator] 1/3 of respondents in a poll
late last year indicated
they would take up arms
to defend the country if it was attacked.
This woman has been
training as a reservist
in the Ukrainian army for 18 months.
- I came here to the
Territory Defense Forces
to have the skills to use the gun
to defend myself, to defend my family
from possible Russian aggression.
(guns clicking)
- [Narrator] Ukraine, which
is the largest country
in the region apart from Russia,
said it's been strengthening its military
and prepared its people to fight.
- There's also a fighting spirit
that has improved since 2014.
People who are ready to
defend their country,
not only in the army
but also volunteers, people bringing help
to those who are ready to fight.
- [Narrator] Still,
there are also residents
in Ukraine's border regions
who say they feel more
closely tied to Russia
than the West.
(Vladimir speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] The US and NATO
have offered their support,
although Western allies remain divided.
The White House has previously
ruled out sending troops
on the ground in Ukraine
but has sent weaponry and
other equipment to the country,
having approved $200
million in such assistance.
- If they actually do what
they're capable of doing
with the force amassed on the border,
it is going to be a disaster for Russia.
- [Narrator] Other NATO members
also sent arms to Ukraine,
while the bloc increased deployments
of troops and equipment in
its eastern member states.
But some European countries like Germany
and Italy were reluctant
to take stronger action,
partly because they are major importers
of energy from Russia.
- Russia will be held accountable.
- [Narrator] So far, the
Biden administration's
main strategy has been the threat
of crippling economic sanctions on Russia,
which hasn't backed down on its demands
and continued military
activity along the border.
(pensive music)